initiating system
one system one
[Music]
loaded
that's what I do when I'm
bored
[Applause]
[Music]
the
[Applause]
[Music]
for
yeah that's your cute a clap you got it
all right so since it's right after
lunch I wanted to do something that you
most most of you probably won't like
stand
up and I'm out you're out all right when
I say three I want you to to yell in
your native language I love Copenhagen
no I love Copenhagen developers Festival
ready
no one two
3 you didn't put your hands
up all right do it again one two
three
okay whatever you said that's
right all right now that we've shaking
off
the the lunchtime Asian stuff right uh
I'm David McCarter welcome to rock your
code code and app performance for
microsoft.net and I'm really excited to
do this here for the first time because
I'm showing I'm going to show you all
the differences between performance of
done at 6 and eight okay and this is the
first first time I'm really talking
about it in public I've been saving this
up for months and uh you guys will be
the first ones to see it and I'm even
amazed about some of the things I'm
seeing atet 8et 8 has dramatically sped
up in most areas I'll show you at the
very end what hasn't but I'll show you
all the stuff that has well not all the
stuff but as much as I can cram into an
hour all right I'm David mcarter I'm
Microsoft MVP I've been doing. net
before it's even was released I'm also a
C Corner MVP feed writer uh architect
cold quality whatever there's all my
handles uh that'll be at the end too if
you didn't grab it at the beginning if
you want to contact me later all
right this talk is based off of that
book uh called Rock your code code and
that performance for microsoft.net just
like this talk okay so if you didn't
hear everything today you can get the
you can get book I also have two other
books out uh a coding centers book and
also one I released two months ago which
is surviving the technal interview so if
you're looking for a job you need that
book okay uh because uh because I'll
tell you why because you all suck at
interviewing so that's that's why the
book is there all right all
right I'm a little nervous for some
reason maybe it's my oh I want to how
many people actually live in Denmark
wow
awesome I've been here since Sunday and
I really like this place uh all right so
today we're going to talk about uh why
we're here then some general tips really
quick just to get you started and some
of the practices I do then we'll talk
about some of the big things uh strings
and Collections and then Source
generators how many have played with
Source generators yet a few okay and
then we're out of here in uh beard time
oh it's not five is it
sorry it's five o'clock somewhere
yeah all
right I did photography for her a few
years
back awesome awesome
guitarist all
right so the goal of this session is to
quickly get some performance increases
in your code as soon as you go home on
Monday or tomorrow or whatever okay uh
there was a workshop here for two days
that really drilled down for your
specific problems on eeking out that
last little performance but this is
going to be more top level and I'll I'll
tell you why in a second because these
These are basically the exact same
things I do every company I go work at
because they all suffer from memory
problems and performance problems every
single problem project I'm hired on to
okay and so these are all those things
uh that I've been finding for many many
many years that people keep doing wrong
and I don't know why
so um you know code performance is
really really important for everything
these days but especially for cloud
because you know we we all know that we
get charged Pro you how long that code
is executing right so if you can cut it
by half that's half your cost right and
companies you know like Facebook you
know hire people right out of college
for 250 Grand uh 250k US dollar a month
just to eek out a million dollars worth
of performance because it's worth it to
them okay so I'm not going to teach you
how to e out a million dollars worth but
enough to get your apps a lot better and
both are very important for now and the
future a lot of things people don't
think about is the future right and if
you code stuff right in the beginning
then things will be a lot easier to
change and memory affects performance
and performance affects memory so I have
a whole separate talk about memory that
I'm not doing here uh but if you go
Google it or Bing it or whatever you'll
be able to find it uh because they both
go hand in hand and really when I go
into a brand new
project the Asian food's coming out of
my mouth sorry um when I go to a brand
new project the first thing I do is fix
all their memory problems because every
100% of the projects I work on have
memory issues and I'm not talking about
old guy memory issues I'm talking about
cold Cod memory
issues
so the the way I got really interested
in this is a company not far from where
I live hired me uh because they only had
two super busy traffic days a year the
rest of the rest of the year is pretty
flat and and um and their biggest
traffic days were Black Friday in
America which is the day after our
Thanksgiving right and then Cyber Monday
which is the Monday after that okay and
that's when they were spiking to 20,000
transactions per second average uh sorry
and spikes to 50,000 transactions per
second only those two days the rest of
the the year was pretty flat
okay and we had one customer who was
Nike and don't get me talk to me
afterwards why they did this but they
put the Nike the entire Nike catalog in
memory 200 gigs which took two hours to
reboot that
machine yeah don't get me started on why
they they chose to do that but they did
but one of the things that I did there
was not only did I get them through
Black Friday and Cyber Monday with no
problems which they were having every
single year before me um but I was
allowing them to start moving their
stuff to the cloud because 200 gabt of
memory is not going to move to the cloud
right so that's why they hired me and I
was successful in that
company all
right so code performance here's are
just a quick easy tips these are things
I always look at when I'm looking at uh
projects and files uh to make sure
things are cleaned up I like to keep
things nice and clean and organized the
first thing is remove all all the usings
in your at the top of your code files
right and I'll tell you why in a second
but you need to remove those because
that can
actually sorry hurt
performance okay and the second thing
you need to do after you do that I think
it's control K D or something like that
cleans them up if you want to do the uh
the the switch um but I usually just use
code rush because when I save the file
code Rush will clean it up all four and
I don't have to worry about it and then
the next thing you need to do right
after that is to get rid of all the
references in your projects you're not
using anymore right and inevitably
there's going to be some especially when
during development you're going to add
things you're going to forget to remove
it you go to add things forget to remove
it and pretty soon you have a big
bloated you know uh deployment and you
don't really need it okay so first clean
up all your usings and then clean up all
your references okay and you'll be a
much better uh for at least that the way
that goes and that's the way that screen
looks
like oops sorry so one thing in all my
sessions is everything you're about to
see is real I don't make this stuff up
because I don't code like this anymore
uh and all of this is real from uh past
projects I've been
on I've changed a little bit so uh I
don't get in trouble sued um
I still see people doing
this right they're initializing
variables to their default State stop it
okay you're hurting your performance not
a huge but it adds up when you're doing
50,000 transactions for second right um
so stop doing that I don't know why
people do that um because those that
that's the default state of those two
types right the default of an integer is
zero the default of a a reference type
is
null okay so stop doing that uh only set
it to something
different if it's not the default okay
and again you're going to I'm not going
to show you the performance stuff on
this because it's not a lot but it does
add up okay so make sure you go through
your code there's actually code editor
stuff um I'm sorry editor config uh
settings you can do to help you uh
prevent that I'll give you those at the
end all right so let's talk about the
first big thing strings right strings is
always a memory issue most of the time
especially if you don't do it right
because
why why is strings a
problem immutable right so even though
you're concatenating two strings you're
really you're hurting performance when
you're doing
that so detecting empty strings this is
one thing that most UI should do
especially when you know any value
coming from the user is probably wrong
right so the first thing we do is we
check to make sure there's actually
something in the string because if we do
any method if we call any methods after
that it's going to blow up on us right
and I still see people doing
this right I this is like donet one kind
of coding right cut it out don't do that
um
what you really should be doing is using
isol or empty or isol or widespace if
you really need that that's a lot less
performant okay how many people do
that good some hands are down I'll slap
you
later
um so make sure you always do that I'm
going to show you the performance which
has changed a lot between six and eight
so you can actually see here I've tested
all kinds of different ways of doing the
same thing pattern matching is actually
a tiny bit faster uh now than is is n or
empty okay so my suggestion would be to
use pattern matching or is nler empty I
probably will stick with his n or empty
because I don't know what's going to
happen with those other things his n or
empty has worked perfectly for a very
long time okay um oh I'm sorry that's uh
see that's the difference between done
at uh seven and uh six now look uh
between six and
8 yeah dramatic change isn't it so now
you can almost say uh you can use just
about anything except for isolo white
space right but I like I said I'm going
to stick with isol or empty because
that's the way it's it's worked fine
since the beginning
okay comparing strings so this is
important especially um those of you who
are have programs that need to take care
of multiple languages in locals right so
uh a lot of people including that
company that was doing 50,000
transactions per
second was comparing strings like this
right they had a lowercase string and
they had some other string and they did
it to lower and then compared it like
that okay that does not work with
multiple languages okay to lower does
not work correctly
okay
um what I recommend now which is a
little bit different than the last time
I did this talk is use two upper and
variant okay this will take care of
those globalization issues and you're
going to see here it's not the fastest
but it's the
safest so you can see there to lower
invariant to Upper invariant a little
bit slower than two upper to lower but
don't use two Upp or to lower okay uh if
you're using multiple languages which
you you will someday okay and there's
their uh metrics for the rest of
it
okay string Builder who uses string
Builder to concatenate strings
what that's
it okay I'll change your mind
um so if you have a new string Builder
before which is like half of you uh you
create string Builder you go through a
loop you append things together and then
you spit it out into a string right a
string Builder will always be more
performant than using plus plus equals
or Plus+ or whatever okay and you can
see um concat and Joint actually uses
underneath the covers it uses a string
Builder underneath the covers but you
can see the speed difference between uh
plus and plus equals right dramatic
difference right
um now if we use a string
Builder there's basically the same kind
of things and you can see string Builder
is 21 times faster than plus equals so
the half of you that are still doing
that that's what you're going to do
Monday right because 21 times faster I
think is pretty awesome by doing just a
little bit of extra code
okay but wait there's
more I don't know if you have
advertisements like that here um so
something newer for the string Builder
there's an extension method that
basically uh you can use string Builder
from an object pull how many people have
used object pulls in net one two three
okay you're going to like this uh so
with an object pull it basically pulls
these objects together so they're not
being created every single time you need
it right so it's really easy to use
First in a private uh field you create
an object pull by using Create um a
create string Builder pool and then you
get it from the pool like that and then
you use it just like the string Builder
right and then when you're done you put
it back okay and because I'm really
worry about uh eror you know exceptions
and things like that I I wrap it into
try finally if you if you take that off
it'll probably be a little bit faster uh
but I'm I like to be safer than uh cause
exceptions in the
program so now watch
this so a
pend is 1.4 times faster than string
Builder so that's not I mean a huge
amount of difference but it's still a
lot better okay if you're really trying
to get that last little bit of uh uh
performance out of your strings and uh
because of the object pull I've changed
everywhere I use strings in my open
source project called Spartan to use
object pull I don't use string builder
in the traditional way anymore so if you
want to go check out my repository you
can see how you see how I did
thatat safy thread
safety um in regards
[Music]
to no no they get in the put back it
works perfectly yeah because I test all
this you know being these methods that I
test uh I'll tell you what I use later
you know they're hit millions of times
and that's what I how I come up with
these you know benchmarks so yeah it's
fine okay regular Expressions how many
people people use regular
Expressions how many people like Regular
Expressions oh come on you're pulling my
leg right
um so I I know a lot of people don't
like using regular Expressions because
uh they're kind of a pain to come up
with and uh they're a pain right and uh
I have found I'll give you a tip it's in
one of my articles I I recently wrote
uh that chat GPT is really good at doing
regular Expressions a lot better than me
so uh there's your tip for the day so
anyway normally you use regular
expression you create the the regular
expression with the pattern then you do
his match or whatever else you're doing
and that's the way that's been done
forever inet
right speeding up regular Expressions so
now if you just you if you just move the
Declaration of that regular expression
to a field a private readon field at the
top of your
class and use it that way watch the uh
performance
increase oh wait is that the
performance oh yeah see I forget where I
put multiple things so there's eight and
six uh with the validating strings uh
with contains that's the normal way of
doing regular
expressions and this is the newer way of
Expressions where default at least in
this uh test is 21 times faster during
regular expression and zero
allocations and the other one has a lot
of
allocations
okay so start using it that way don't
use it the old way but I I have more
coming up on that
later all right any questions real
quick the
what compile compile is the
slowest
yes according to my Benchmark tests it's
the slowest that's why I don't talk
about it
yeah
huh
yeah I will next I'll put it back next
time but the reason I took it out is
because it skews the graph so
bad that you know everything will be
this big and the compiled will be this
big right
so no it's only compiling
once y
if you can show me how it works better
let me
know yeah I don't know either okay so
collections uh you know we all use
collections because that's how we use
our data most of the most of these days
especially coming from a database and
you can achieve a lot of of really big
performance gains by doing collections
and before I forget you know the the
last contract I was on when I started
the company
their goal was to have 40,000 concurrent
users when I started uh because they
were about to launch uh this program in
uh this application in India and when I
got there they had a they could only
handle a 100 concurrent
users yeah uh it doesn't work does it
and so by the time I left six months
later I had them up to
7,000 and they still have a ways to go
but at least I was moving them along the
way and and and all these things is what
I'm going to what I did for them is what
I'm about to show you so uh generating a
bite
array um this is how I see most people
creating a bite array by using the
random um type and just doing next bites
and creating a bite array like that
actually my open source project did that
until very very recently
okay don't use that anymore use random
number
generator
okay so create a random number generator
in a field and then use get bites just
like you were before but you're just
moving it up to be instead use the
random number
generator okay it's much much more
performant as you can
see what eight times faster and the
allocations are just about identical
okay so stop using random for generating
by
start using a a random number
generator
okay any versus how many uses any to see
if there's something in a
collection okay um so they've added a
new one called exists and they both can
take predicates like you see
here but look at the difference
yep so if use exist now and down at8 at
least uh it's four times faster okay so
those of you using any cut it out and uh
start using
exists and I've got more in that coming
up in a
second iterating through a
collection so forever and doet we've had
these four ways of going through a
collection right four doe while and four
each
right how many people use four or four
each most of the
time okay you need a copy of my
performance book because every uh I'll
I'll I'll it's going to come up here in
a second but every collection type and
every type of type operates differently
you just can't blank you can just can't
do a blanket for each everywhere because
you can hurt your performance doing that
okay so anyway this is
four and you can see here is that down
at eight and six
yeah so the last time I gave this talk
if I'm going through a collection of
reference types of list uh 4 each was
the fastest for years that's why I've
been telling you all to use as 4 each
right now you can see four is actually
slightly
faster okay so basically now do whatever
you
want because dot8 has sped it up so much
is Matt's here I was hoping he was to be
here uh Dada sped up so much that those
things don't really matter a ton anymore
okay so go do whatever you want but I'm
probably going to still use 4 h
and zero allocations which is always
good so is link really faster how many
people use Link to quy their
objects
okay
um so I did an any and basically
reproduced it in a loop and the loop was
faster than
any okay so I guess my little note on
this one is you know before you just
start all going using link make
sure the old way of doing it isn't
faster okay so test both and see which
one is faster and use that
okay I know we're all lazy CU we like
link but so here's the tip about the
different collection
types so every
collection type uh the performance is
based on the collection type and the
object type okay if and like I said if
you get a copy on my book it's all
listed in there okay whether you're
using dictionary array list I I test
every single collection type that comes
and done that
okay and the other tip
[Music]
is I forgot what it
is uh oh yeah so far the guy over there
there was question me the other a couple
minutes ago uh using any of the parallel
stuff is slower I have not been able to
get the parallel code to work faster
than using normal code okay you're your
results May Vary and probably will but I
can't get it to go faster it's actually
a lot
slower all right so we're back to
validating items at collection again
uh a lot of people use count or any and
that one company I worked at that was
doing 50,000 transactions per second
they were using any everywhere okay
every single time they were testing a
collection if there's something in it
they were just using any brackets that's
it
okay so you can use count you can use
any you can use Long Count you you can
use try get non enumerated count so
there's many different ways ways of of
doing the same thing at doet now so
which one is faster uh
count okay so in this case at least for
reference types a list of reference
types count is slightly faster actually
it's about half the speed as any and
then uh Long Count is the slowest okay
so if using Long Count I would recommend
uh not to do
that and there's the allocations there
you can see the allocations for count is
very very small compared to the other
ones all right verifying array contents
so for arrays don't use
count okay uh you should use length or
something else I'll show you in a second
okay um count is is uh typically been
slower with arrays okay so now if I test
long l length length count any and Long
Count long length now is actually a
little bit faster than
length Okay where that was swapped the
last time I did this
talk uh last time I did it length was
faster and long length uh was actually I
think after
count
okay so now you can start using I would
use length or long length Okay when
you're doing arrays okay but only array
okay the rest of the stuff is okay it's
just the Rays operate a little bit
differently and zero
allocations all right let's talk about
link um I've been using link before it's
before it came out and this is the way a
lot of people still use Link by using
the uh I mean still use uh uh link by
using the API okay how many people do
link like
this only
one two okay uh so there's kind of the
older way we've always done it but now
we can use lambdas right basically the
exact same thing you can use a Lambda do
first so which link call is faster do
you think do you think it's the
API or the expression who who chooses
the API
two all of you using the API should be
choosing it
right it's actually
Lambda okay and this was actually posed
to me when I was uh doing a contract at
Verizon where some developer told
somebody I was mentoring he had to
change all the Lambda Expressions back
to the API and he came to me and goes
Dave I don't I don't want to change all
that code is it really faster did a
benchmark test uh
no so tell whatever lead developer you
have uh he's not
right yeah at the end hold on
SEC so finding items in D how many
people use
dictionaries yep a lot of people do how
many code dictionaries like
that come
on only some of you I thought there'd be
more all right so when you code
addiction if you're looking something up
in a dictionary like this this is the
safe way of doing it right first check
make sure it's there and then and then
get it right but you're doing a double
lookup at this point okay you're
basically doing the same operation
twice okay so uh cut that
out just use try get value okay most of
the time at net when you see a try get
value it's going to be more performant
okay um and it works the same way really
if try get value then update the value
okay but look at the speed
difference try get value with uh ordinal
is fastest then try get value and then
the other two are slower okay so if you
can use ordinal whether that's you know
with a collection or even strings
ordinal can actually speed things up
okay but again make sure you test
that all right
question
right yeah and you always have to think
about what you're using it for and what
kind of types you're using in that right
so yeah my blanket blanket blanket
statement might not apply everywhere
right that's why you need to test your
code and see which way is
better regarding uh linku expression
versus Lambda so link all linku
Expressions will be uh uh turned into uh
Lambda Expressions before
execution the API does yeah that is the
underlying C why it will be always
faster oh yeah yeah I didn't even know
that yeah see I learned something today
all right okay that's was it yeah
thanks all
right so Source generators how many have
used Source generators yet just a few
hopefully I'll change your
mind while I'm way I'm going way too
fast you need to ask more
questions uh so I've been really really
really pleased with the performance I've
been seeing with sorcer inovator
I want to write my own I haven't got
around to it yet because it's not the
easiest thing to do um but generally at
least everything I've been able to test
a source generators can dramatically
speed up your code
okay
sure you tested with string um what
about the new read only span Char any
test with that yes yes I have and do you
know if string Builder is going to be
able to create a read only span it's
going to be do what like right now it
seems a bit waste like sometimes you use
the string Builder and then you have to
you put two string into something which
uses a read only chart why can't string
Builder just create a read only uh span
of chars like so they should have a
you're asking me well I don't know if I
get enough Mod Mo like momentum maybe I
we can get it done right well you know
the architect of CP is here right all
right well there you
go yeah I'll I'll talk to him later
about
that uh huh it makes sense yep it does
does
um so uhet be I'm not going to this is
not a talk about Source generators uhet
right now only ships with just a handful
of source generators there's a there's a
GitHub page out there somewhere that l
it's like almost every single one that
somebody else has created to so I'm only
going to show you a few but there's a
lot more out there you just got to uh
Google it or Bing it or whatever you
want um or write your own
right so Source generators basically
work with attributes and it looks at
your code and then preens the code for
you okay and that's how you can get this
really big
import performance incase sorry it's hot
up here um by using Source
generators and Source generators
actually started and done at six okay
and they keep adding them you know with
every new version they're adding more
and more uh Source generators I hope
they add more I think there there's a
lot of room uh for Microsoft to add more
but so far there's not a ton in the
framework
itself so Jason serialization this is
something that we do constantly right
we're always changing things in and out
of Jason um going across the wire
whatever you want to
do and this is a way this is in my uh uh
open source project this is from my open
source project and this is how you can
do uh use Source generators with a just
a single type up there at the top so you
can see uh person proper Jason
serializer
context and then I have one down
right below that for a collection of
that same type okay because they
actually act a little bit differently
okay so and that's all you have to do
you just have to declare it in a public
I mean a partial class that's it that's
all the code right there I
wrote and you use it almost exactly the
same as the old way you can see
serialization is sorry exactly the same
but deserialization is a little bit
different because we're using the
context down there at the end as person
proper
okay and that's like I said that's what
you use for the
collections and now look at the speed
increase right
deserialize a lot slower than the
generator and serial serialize is almost
the same so you're not getting a lot on
serialization but you are getting a lot
on the
deserialization thanks
sense
yep so I would start using that now it's
it's a little more work to set this up
but it as you can see it really pays off
was that overd double the performance
for D seral
station who logs in their
code why isn't every hand
up um so typically this is the way we
log right with the new ilogger interface
in net I'm really glad they added that
um but how many people log like this
now really what else do you
use
nlog well this is using Siri log or
whatever underneath the
covers so this is the way most people
log with I logger right they just do
logger log air give it the number the
exception and the message right but we
all want you know I've worked at
companies where you know they they
basically told me we don't do a lot of
logging because of the performance and I
go well then how do you fix
stuff sometimes I can never get it
through people's heads so this is how
the logger Source generator generator
works I'm saying that too many times uh
uh logger message is the
attribute and then you basically do the
same thing except with the placeholder
for the message so you can see I have a
public static partial void log error it
takes ey logger it takes a message
that's it
okay and then I use it pretty much this
is from my open source project I have a
type in there called easy logger that
uses the source generator generator
underneath the covers and you can do it
like normal okay
but
look what is that 11 times
faster using a sourc orator gosh I've
said that word way too many times
now that's dramatically faster don't you
think yeah so how many going to start
using
that back at work I hope
so uh yeah I wouldn't use the old way at
all
anymore all
right Rex now we're back to Rex
okay now there is a new source generator
for RX
okay and this is how I have it set up in
my open source project where I have the
options um up there in the field I have
uh uh the actual pattern up there as a
Rex contains word and then you just use
an attrib just like that do reject
contains word that's
it okay it's all you have to do to set
up the uh redj Source generator okay and
the one thing I really like about the
redj source generator I I don't remember
who wrote it it writes really good
intellisense and it tells you exactly
how it's matching the patterns in it I
really like it but it but but what that
does is that single attribute basically
creates like a couple hundred lines of
code and that's what shorts rators do
they do all this stuff in
advance and
look contains
word is 36 times faster than normal and
six times faster than using the
field okay and looking for uh replace
spaces is 2.5 2.4 times faster than
normal and two times faster than the the
field okay so if you are using uh
regular Expressions I really really
really recommend you start using this
okay again it's a little more coding
don't be afraid of coding it's okay um
but you can see the big performance
increase you get from
that I like that
one all right
any questions you over
there
no no that's
okay I'm kidding any other
questions
[Music]
um yeah yeah um I I don't know the
differences off the top of my head but
me personally I usually use code I don't
use the data valid Val the the what was
it called dat anot data annotations yeah
I don't use those very much I use code
yep and whenever you're validating data
it's going to slow things down a little
bit right it's it's a nature of the
Beast you can't really change that you
know so uh don't validate any more than
you need
to you know and uh and uh and only
validate what you really need to
validate right um but my if you look at
my open source project I validate
everything except for booleans basically
right
uh because uh you know we all know bad
data in bad data out and once that bad
data B bad data gets into the database
it's really really hard to fix right and
uh for many many many years I have an
architecture that I use where I put all
that validation into one assembly so it
can be used throughout servers clients
whatever right I put it in one place and
basically so when I uh set up uh models
right data models right I put all the
data models in their own assembly and
that's the only thing in there okay
because that way that as long as you're
using net everywhere you can use that on
the server you can use it on the client
you can use it wherever you want right
and because most people uh when they do
stuff like that they put the the models
along with the data context and I've
never done that because that just you're
not separating it out enough and you
basically have to start uh uh rewriting
your validation code everywhere right so
yeah I keep everything separate any
other
questions yeah I'm sorry I'm uh
returning to one of the previous uh
string and uh string Builder uh have you
done uh the any measurements on
interpolated
strings yes um so typically interpolated
strings um
I'm trying to remember my benchmarks
right now uh
there so before I answer that uh uh I
don't really use interpolated strings
okay um anybody guess why I don't like
interpolated
strings Nobody Does anybody have a
program that works in two different
spoken
languages nobody
come on you're in
Denmark nobody okay so here's my role
interpret related strings I only use
them for error
messages that's it okay because you
can't globalize those right uh right now
at least last time I looked you can't
use them with resources right and
anything I showed to the user is in a
resource anything okay because that way
it can be easily translated
and if you come to build uh build stuff
in Lithuania in a couple months I'll
show you exactly how to do
that okay because I'm doing a whole
workshop on globalization one of my
favorite subjects well it's not really
my favorite but I never see anybody do
it right yeah any other
questions Downs to a generator because
for something like log error
or might as well just include that comp
always I have not found a downside to
source source generators yet yeah I'm
going to tell mads to rame that because
it's messing my mouth
up um but now I haven't seen any
downsides it it makes your code uh
creates more code uh so a bigger
deployment but that's about it yeah I
don't see any
downsides any other questions
yes there was just a comment that you're
using interpolated strings for the error
messages which is the one place you
shouldn't use it for in logs huh in I
shouldn't use interpolated strings for
error messages yeah you shouldn't try
doing the the you can read on it online
as well they're like half your
performance on logging you should be
putting it in the parameters that you're
passing what you want the actual value
used to
be no seriously check then it it will
affect your performance even worse and
the other stuff you shown but hopefully
you're not generating those error
strings very much right yeah well I'm
not I'm just saying man if you want to
talk at the log statistics then have a
look at interpolated strings it's like
uh one of the first things like 101
don't do it h maybe Microsoft should
remove that
then but you can't remove it because
it's passing the string as a message but
I know I'm using it they've they've
allowed you to add parameters afterwards
yeah stuff that you want passed I'll
look into that but
yeah anything the user cares about
should be in new
resource that's my my my golden
role the way I showed you it's fine yeah
it won't it won't make any difference
because they're not those variables
aren't being changed right so for
scalability it work
fine okay am I running low on
battery I forgot to bring my
uh uh my converter so I better hurry
up all
[Music]
right
sorry I had to listen to a little bit of
metal uh so nearly everything is sped up
and down at eight except for
that so um I'm showing you at the very
end because I'm not super worried about
this yet until they come out with the
final release because things change you
know between every release uh this is uh
all these benchmarks were done uh off
the August
SDK okay so it'll change in the next one
next month okay uh but the when I looked
at it those things are not performing as
well as they used to be okay uh so watch
out for my uh blog site and now if it if
those things hold true I'll be writing
blog posts about it okay to warn you
all right so the last thing is you know
unless you wrote a book on performance
it's really hard to remember a lot of
this stuff and you know the last version
of my book I learned a lot uh just
writing uh that version of it I think
it's the third version
um but you might not remember all these
things I have a hard time most of the
time remembering these things and I'm
sure a lot of your Junior Developers
won't ever remember these things so if
you want these things to be
uncovered uh when you build uh put these
settings in your editor
config okay the editor config that
Visual Studio creates is sucks sorry uh
my editor config I think is over whoops
over 2,000 lines the one that Visual
Studio creates is uh like uh 50 lines or
less okay I've spent many many many many
many hours trying to scour the the web
on all the settings you can put in your
editor config and they're in mind so if
you go to that URL right there you can
get the editor config that I use at
every single project I work on okay and
I update that editor editor config every
time I make a major update to my open
source project which is once a quarter
okay so if you get it now make sure you
check back in a quarter because I'm
always changing things I change things
not only because I find things but I
also change the settings based on what I
see developers doing if I see developers
doing the same thing over and over again
I usually turn those to errors or
Warnings not suggestions or messages
okay so make sure you get that there's a
uh section in my editor config that all
about performance I don't know how many
settings are in there uh but every
single one I could find
okay
my last
tip uh Benchmark your
code how do you know if it's any faster
if you're not benchmarking it okay and
I'm not talking about the speed of h2b
calls and things like that of just the
code itself okay so I was I I think I
was telling mads earlier that uh the
benchmark test for my book
takes over 3 Days To
Run there's tens of thousands of
benchmarks that I use for my book and it
takes a really really long time to run
uh but I use I religiously use
benchmark.com you should be using
be based on the types that you're
using okay because like I said different
types perform
differently okay so make sure you
Benchmark if you're ever like that guy
remember I told you a story a little bit
ago about the uh the the link API and
the and the lambdas right that's exactly
what I did when he came to me that night
at home I wrote the code and proved the
lead developer
wrong okay and I went back to that uh
the person I was mentoring and I said
yeah don't listen to
him listen to
me all right uh oh I want to promote my
show so uh I have a show uh twice
monthly now that coid is over um it's
called Rock in the cold world uh with
Don at Dave it's a on Saturdays at 10:
a.m. PST I uh interview everybody at big
wigs at Microsoft all the way down to
you guys okay not that you're low or
anything
but uh so uh uh I'm in season 3 right
now I uh season two finished with over
250,000 people uh watching the show and
season 4 starts on October 7th with mad
tenson who's here who did the community
event last night and he'll be on talking
about all the cool stuff coming out down
at eight okay so I hope you join us
mad's an awesome guy I've known him for
years now
and uh we even uh spent two days touring
uh Delhi India together that was really
fun
um so I hope you go watch my show it's
all recorded on it's simoc cast on like
five different platforms so watch it
wherever you want uh but watch okay
because uh I tackle a lot of things that
people either don't know about or just
stuff I care about like uh the beginning
of this month I had someone on talking
about mental health at work work
something we all
need and then uh uh the week after that
I had somebody on talking about impostor
syndrome something that we all have
right so I hope you uh watch those shows
uh because uh I work really hard with uh
my producer and uh I love doing a show I
love talking to people on Saturdays uh
because I have nothing better to do no
I'm kidding I have lots better to do I
live a mile from the beach so um
here's some resources my website sourcer
inovator so I've dedicated myself to
write really really good documentation
for the Microsoft sourcer inators which
has really bad documentation right so
every time Microsoft adds a new one I'll
be adding it there um I have another um
article called reuse reuse and more
reuse something I practice and preach
and on that one you know one thing I've
been preaching for a very very long time
is 90% of your code should not be in the
application for many many reasons and
talk to me later if you want to know
what those
reasons uh there's my open source
project there's a link to my
show um I've only found two courses on
plural site wrapped around this that I
like one's done by uh clean code by
Corey house a great speaker if you get
to see him live and then someone who's
been my friend since the '90s de Kata
has a c best practices so check that out
too all right with that thanks and uh
see you next
time